This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When you own a home, water is your greatest enemy. So much work is put into keeping water from coming in, and so much engineering is built into getting whatever water that inevitably seeps in back out again before it pools and causes rod. This is one of the reasons why I'm so fascinated by the houseboats of Sauselito, California, which seemed to tempt fate with their very existence. The floating homes that fill up and spill out past the docks of this Marin County town started appearing at the turn of the 20th century, but it was during World War Two when tens of thousands of people flooded into the area to work in the shipyards that the real housing boom
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。当你拥有自己的房子时，水就是你最大的敌人。人们花了大量心血来防止水渗进来，又运用了大量的工程设计，在水积聚并引起腐烂之前，把不可避免渗进来的水再排出去。这就是为什么我对加利福尼亚州索萨利托的船屋如此着迷的原因，它们的存在本身似乎就是在向命运发起挑战。填满这个马林县城镇码头并向外延伸的浮动房屋，在20世纪之交开始出现；但正是在二战期间，成千上万的人涌入该地区在造船厂工作，真正的住房热潮
along the saucy little waterfront began. Housing was scarce and workers made homes out of old boats and any other materials they could scrounge. Today there's a wide variety of houseboats dotted along the bay. Some are real boats that could unmoor and sail across the sea. But many have no means of locomotion at all and are just houses on floating palettes. Some are multi-story, opulent weekend retreats, and some look decidedly original recipe, like they were indeed made out of driftwood during World War II.
才在这个小巧迷人的海滨沿岸拉开帷幕。当时住房紧缺，工人们用旧船和他们能搜罗到的任何其他材料搭建房屋。如今，海湾沿岸点缀着各种各样的船屋。有些是真正的船只，可以解缆出海航行。但许多船只根本没有任何动力装置，只是浮动平台上的房子。有些是多层的、豪华的周末度假屋，而有些则看起来绝对是原汁原味，就像它们确实是在二战期间用流木建造的一样。
When the staff came to the Bay Area for our most recent retreat, I took the team kayaking on the bay near the houseboats. It is so peaceful, it is one of my favorite activities. If you enjoy walking under neighborhood and wondering about the lives of the people inside, kayaking near houseboats is like that on acid. It is such a bold choice of lifestyle, your mind goes wild with possibilities. I mostly imagine two types of owners,
当我们的工作人员来到湾区参加最近的静修活动时，我带着团队在船屋附近的海湾划皮划艇。那里非常宁静，是我最喜欢的活动之一。如果你喜欢在居民区散步并对屋内人们的生活充满好奇，那么在船屋附近划皮划艇就像是这种体验的升级版。这是一种如此大胆的生活方式选择，让你的脑海中充满了无限的可能。我主要想象着两类业主，
rich retired folks who want to be present on the water and in scots in a weird, tight bohemian community, and people who have bottomed out and live in the architectural equivalent of steering into the skid. Living on a houseboat may be a good path or a bad path, but it is most definitely a path. In the final episode of our vernacular spectacular anniversary series, 99 PI producers and friends of the show will be sharing more stories of regional architecture, some close to home, some on remote islands that capture our imagination and inspire us to look deeper.
富有的退休人员，他们想在一个奇怪、紧密、波西米亚式的社区里出现在水面上和苏格兰风格中；还有那些陷入生活谷底的人，他们住在建筑学上相当于“顺着侧滑方向打方向盘”的房子里。住在船屋上可能是一条好路，也可能是一条坏路，但它绝对是一条路。在我们地方特色奇观周年系列节目的最后一集中，99 PI制作人和节目的朋友们将分享更多关于区域建筑的故事，有些离家很近，有些在偏远的岛屿上，它们吸引着我们的想象力，并激励我们进行更深入的探索。
Thanks again for joining us and thanks for getting us to 500 and two episodes. A first is digital director, Kurt Colston. A while back, I opened an email from a 99-PI listener located in Bermuda named Amy Daniels, in which she introduced me to her island's remarkable vernacular architecture. So I wrote back to her to find out more. And the next thing I knew, Amy was introducing me to our island's remarkable vernacular architecture. So I wrote back to her to find out more. And the next thing I knew, he was introducing me to a local architect. My name is Colin Campbell. I'm a senior architect for OBM in Bermuda.
再次感谢大家的加入，也感谢你们让我们迎来了第502期节目。首先是数字总监库尔特·科尔顿。不久前，我打开了一封来自百慕大99-PI听众艾米·丹尼尔斯的电子邮件，她在信中向我介绍了她所在的岛屿上引人注目的地方建筑风格。所以我给她回信了解更多信息。接下来的事我知道，艾米正在向我介绍我们岛上引人注目的地方建筑风格。所以我回信给她想了解更多。而接下来我知道的是，他正在向我介绍一位当地的建筑师。我叫科林·坎贝尔。我是百慕大OBM的高级建筑师。
OBM is a firm that started in Bermuda over 85 years ago. And when I asked Colin how he and Amy knew one another, it's Bermuda. It's family. Amy had asked her mother, and her mother was scratched her head, said, oh, I know this, Ella. So everything's two degrees of separation, okay. Exactly, yeah. Exactly.
OBM是一家85年前在百慕大创立的公司。当我问科林他和艾米是怎么认识的时候，这里是百慕大。这里都是一家人。艾米问了她的母亲，她母亲挠了挠头说，哦，我知道这个，埃拉。所以一切都只有两度分隔，好吧。完全正确，是的。完全正确。
Before we got to architecture, I asked Colin to start out by just telling me about Bermuda, which, to be honest, he really sold me on. Bermuda is a place that if it hadn't been made, you couldn't dream it up. It's so crazy beautiful. It's a little island, it's 22 square miles, it's just on the edge of the Gulf Stream, so we have a temperate climate as opposed to a colder North Atlantic climate.
在我们聊到建筑之前，我请科林先跟我讲讲百慕大，说实话，他的介绍真的把我给说动了。百慕大是一个如果你没有创造它，你就梦想不到的地方。它美得太疯狂了。这是一个小岛，面积22平方公里，刚好位于湾流的边缘，所以我们拥有温带气候，而不是寒冷的北大西洋气候。
Colin went on to explain that the first European settlers arrived on this beautiful island back in the 1600s, and a lot of their early buildings were wood-framed and topped off with roofs made of thatched grass. But as we all know from the three little pigs, straw and wood aren't the most robust materials. From almost a hundred years people did a stick-and-frame construction and then after a couple of hurricanes in 1712, 1714 a light bulb went on and the only left standing were stone buildings and so the whole technology changed
科林接着解释说，第一批欧洲定居者在17世纪回到了这个美丽的岛屿，他们早期的大多数建筑都是木结构，屋顶铺着茅草。但正如我们从三只小猪的故事中所知，稻草和木头并不是最坚固的材料。近百年来，人们一直采用木棍和框架结构；然后在1712年和1714年的几次飓风过后，人们恍然大悟，唯一经受住考验并屹立不倒的是石质建筑，于是整个技术发生了改变，
and people started building with native stone. And so stone became a critical part of the island's vernacular. It made for robust walls and it made use of this plentiful local material. And these stone walls were in turn top with heavy stone roofs, which have a noticeably steep slope. A slope, which serves a vital function in a hurricane. It turns out that a shallow roof can really suck during a tropical storm,
人们开始用本土石材建造房屋。因此，石头成了岛上地方建筑风格的关键部分。它造就了坚固的墙壁，并利用了这种丰富的本地材料。而这些石墙反过来又覆有厚重的石屋顶，石屋顶有一个明显的陡坡。这个坡度在飓风中起着至关重要的作用。事实证明，在热带风暴期间，平缓的屋顶真的很糟糕，
while a steep roof, well, I'll just let Colin explain it. It doesn't suffer suction, which is the big problem in a hurricane. There's a wind goes rushing over a roof. If the roof has a lower pitch, it acts as a wing and you have lift. And many buildings are torn apart, not by the wind pushing it, but the suction forces that collect on the other side of the roof. So these slightly higher pitched roofs here in Bermuda also act to create enough turbulence that they break the suction forces and they stay intact. So the roof pitch helps, but the most distinctive part of these rooftops visually isn't the slope. It's the way overlapping stone slats make the sides of each roof look like a bright white staircase. And this style of Bermuda roof serves a purpose related to another feature of the island's climate. And what this does is it slows the water down.
而陡峭的屋顶，好吧，我还是让科林来解释吧。它不会遭受吸力的影响，这是飓风中的大问题。当风呼啸着掠过屋顶时，如果屋顶的坡度较低，它就会像机翼一样产生升力。许多建筑被撕裂，不是因为风的推力，而是因为屋顶另一侧聚集的吸力。因此，百慕大这些稍微陡峭一点的屋顶还能产生足够的湍流，打破吸力，使它们保持完好。所以屋顶的坡度有帮助，但从视觉上看，这些屋顶最独特的部门并不是坡度，而是重叠的石板使每个屋顶的两侧看起来像一处亮白色的楼梯。这种百慕大屋顶的风格有着与岛上气候的另一个特征相关的目的。而这所做的是减缓水的流速。
If the water hits the roof, instead of going rushing down on a flat plain surface, it has to go down a step. So while the overall pitch of the roof is steep, that's offset by this staircase shape, which keeps water from running down and off the sides too quickly. Almost like a little river going through pebbles and the like. So it slows the water down so you can capture the water at the gutter level and you're not losing it over the edge of the waves.
如果水击中屋顶，它不是顺着平坦的表面急流而下，而是必须走下一个台阶。因此，虽然屋顶的整体坡度很陡，但这被这种楼梯形状所抵消，楼梯形状可以防止水流过快地向下流过两侧。几乎就像一条小河流过鹅卵石之类的东西。所以它减缓了水的速度，这样你就可以在沟槽水平收集水，而不会让水从波浪边缘流失。
Catching water has been an essential function of houses of remuda almost since the beginning. And that was important because the homes did not have wells or any type of common water distribution systems. So we capture the rain water for our potable water. And this got started in 1612 with their mouths just because there was insufficient water on the island available through wells and the lake. Early settlers also came up with a clever way to top off these roofs, a coating of white
几乎从一开始，蓄水就是百慕大房屋的一项必不可少的功能。这很重要，因为房屋没有水井或任何类型的公共供水系统。因此，我们收集雨水作为饮用水。这始于1612年，原因仅仅是岛上通过水井等渠道获得的可用水严重不足。早期的定居者还想出了一种巧妙的方法来给这些屋顶收尾——涂上一层白色的
lime. This bright finish helped keep houses cool by reflecting sunlight while the lime helped purify incoming water. Of course, for this whole clever water collection system to work, it has to rain. Thankfully, the island's rainfall is generally pretty consistent. But not always. We have certainly seen in the last couple of years where you go two months or almost three months without any reasonable rainfall. To help hedge these dry spells, a typical Bermuda home can store an astonishing amount of water. Houses today will carry anywhere
石灰。这种明亮的饰面通过反射阳光来保持房屋凉爽，同时石灰有助于净化进入的水。当然，为了让这个聪明的集水系统发挥作用，必须下雨。值得庆幸的是，该岛的降雨量通常相当稳定。但并非总是如此。我们当然在过去几年中看到过这种情况，那就是连续两个月甚至几乎三个月都没有降雨。为了应对这些干旱期，一栋典型的百慕大住宅可以储存惊人数量的水。如今的房屋蓄水量可达
from 12 to 40,000 gallons of water. Every house has its own water pump and pressure system. Why that's important, especially in a hurricane-prone zone, such as Bermuda, is that in the instance of a loss of power, you can still get fresh water, because every house is self-sustaining. This combination of self-sufficiency and the durability of local architecture helps the island bounce back incredibly fast from even major weather events. We don't appear to suffer the amount of damage you see in some of the other islands and the
1.2万至4万加仑。每栋房子都有自己的水泵和压力系统。这之所以重要，尤其是在百慕大这样易受飓风袭击的地区，是因为在断电的情况下，你仍然可以获得淡水，因为每栋房子都是自给自足的。这种自给自足与当地建筑的耐用性相结合，帮助该岛即使在遭遇重大天气事件后也能以惊人的速度恢复。在飓风过后的事件中，我们似乎没有遭受在其他一些岛屿和
coastal parts of the United States in the post-Hurricane event. In Brabuda, after a major event, the island has generally had lights on ready to go within 24 or 36 hours. And that's all well and good for the residents of Bermuda. But Cohen is rightfully insistent that these local solutions have global applications too. The approach to conserve water and to use those resources, again, it's going to be critical for the years going forward. And as a strategy for communities which are going to have seasonal droughts. As we know we're all going into a global warming condition. White roofs reflect heat that makes sense. There should be no dark roofs in America we should all be doing that. It's just simple science. I couldn't agree more.
美国沿海地区所看到的那么大破坏。在巴布达，重大事件发生后，岛上的灯光通常在24到36小时内就会恢复并准备就绪。这对百慕大居民来说当然是件好事。但科恩正确地坚持认为，这些地方性的解决方案也具有全球性的应用价值。节约用水和利用这些资源的方针，再次强调，对于未来的岁月至关重要。作为将经历季节性干旱的社区的一项策略。正如我们所知，我们都将进入全球变暖的状态。白色的屋顶反射热量，这是有道理的。美国不应该有黑色的屋顶，我们都应该这样做。这只是简单的科学。我完全赞同。
Architects would do well to study, tried and tested vernacular solutions like these, and not just from Bermuda, but from around the world. A Bermuda roof is only white sometimes. In the reflection of the sky, there's a luminosity that happens. So the roofs are not static white, they shimmer white. And it's the interplay of light and darkness on the roofs, and in the architecture that I find the most satisfying of the whole lot. To see the subtleties, you have to stand and watch it for just a little bit,
建筑师最好研究一下这些久经考验的地方建筑解决方案，不仅来自百慕大，而且来自世界各地。百慕大屋顶有时是白色的。在天空的倒影中，会产生一种光辉。所以屋顶不是静态的白色，而是闪烁的白色。正是屋顶上以及建筑中光与暗的相互作用，让我觉得整个建筑最令人满意。要想看到其中的微妙之处，你必须站在那里看上一小会儿，
and then you go, oh, that's nice, that's great. Living in an ocean environment, this little park in the middle of the great blue sea is spectacular. And as a living human being, I wonder why we're here? I think in Ramuda you can almost figure it out. I'm that close sometimes. Liam O'Donohue is the host and creator of a podcast out of Oakland that we love called East Bay yesterday. And as we're thinking about the architecture around us and what it means to us, we figured he was the perfect person to talk about one of his favorite styles of local architecture that shows up quite a bit in beautiful downtown Oakland, California.
然后你会说，哦，这很好，太棒了。生活在海洋环境中，大海中央的这个小公园真是壮观。作为一个活着的人，我禁不住想，我们为什么在这里？我想在拉姆达，你几乎可以弄明白。有时我就是这么接近。利亚姆·奥多诺休（Liam O'Donohue）是奥克兰一个我们非常喜欢的播客的创始人和主持人，名叫《东湾昨天》（East Bay yesterday）。当我们思考我们周围的建筑及其对我们的意义时，我们觉得他是讨论他最喜欢的一种当地建筑风格的完美人选，这种风格在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心相当常见。
There's a specific style of house that whenever I'm walking, or riding my bike through Oakland that I happen to notice, catches my attention because there's just so many interesting elements to it. And I didn't know what it was called for a long time, but now I am familiar with the term queen and Victorian. So we're in the Bay Area, but we're specifically in the East Bay, which is a little bit different than San Francisco.
每当我步行或骑自行车穿过奥克兰时，我都会注意到一种特定风格的房子，它吸引了我的注意力，因为里面有太多有趣的元素。很长一段时间我不知道它叫什么，但现在我对“安妮女王”和“维多利亚”这个词很熟悉了。所以我们在湾区，但我们具体在东湾，这和旧金山有点不同。
And if you're out here for a while, you know this. But when I think when people think of Bay Area Housing, they think of San Francisco Housing, and they think of those tall, maybe three or four story Victorians, they're the painted ladies that you see during the credits rolling on full house, you know, they're very pretty. I totally love them. They're fancy, they're ornate, they have lots of colors. But those are a part of our area for sure.
如果你在这里呆了一段时间，你就会知道这一点。但我想当人们想到湾区的房屋时，他们会想到旧金山的房屋，他们会想到那些高挑的、也许有三四层楼高的维多利亚式建筑，它们就是你在《欢乐满屋》片尾滚动字幕时看到的彩色的房子，你知道，它们非常漂亮。我完全喜欢它们。它们很华丽，很精致，有很多颜色。但这些肯定是我们地区的一部分。
But Oakland has something like a little bit different, a different variation. Like how do those relate to what we see in Oakland? Absolutely. So the iconic San Francisco Victorians, that everyone knows from the opening scene of Full House, they have a very distinct look. And a big aspect of why they look that way is because even
但奥克兰有一些有点不同的东西，一种不同的变体。这些与我们在奥克兰看到的有什么关系？绝对的。所以每个人都知道的、来自《欢乐满屋》开场镜头的标志性旧金山维多利亚式建筑，它们有着非常独特的外观。它们之所以长成这样，很大程度上是因为
back in the late 1800s, real estate was pretty tight in San Francisco. San Francisco is famously located on the tip of a seven by seven mile peninsula. So even back then, residential lots didn't have a lot of room to sprawl out all over the place. Hence, you get these kind of tall narrow San Francisco Victorians. In Oakland or in the East Bay, on the other hand, there was a little bit more real estate to work with. So the architecture had more room to kind of breathe.
早在19世纪后期，旧金山的房地产就相当紧俏。众所周知，旧金山市坐落在一个7乘7英里的半岛的尖端上。所以即使在当时，住宅用地也没有多少空间可以到处扩张。因此，你得到了这种又高又窄的旧金山维多利亚式建筑。另一方面，在奥克兰或东湾，有更多的房地产可供开发。因此，建筑有更多的空间来呼吸。
They weren't as narrow. And the way that I sort of think about it is imagine those iconic San Francisco Victorians, but if someone like squashed it or sat on it. And these Queen Anne's are like pretty wide ranging. And they were really big. They were small. And they had all kinds of different stuff going on.
它们没有那么窄。我的一种思考方式是，想象一下那些标志性的旧金山维多利亚式建筑，但如果有人把它压扁了或坐在上面。这些安妮女王式建筑的跨度相当广泛。它们真的很大。它们很小。它们有各种各样的不同之处。
Yeah, yeah. So I think one thing that's important for people to realize is that Victorian is a very broad description. It really is a description of an era, a time. So it's like if you're saying, I'm 80s music, you could be referring to punk or pop or a million different styles. It's not really telling you what that music is.
是的，是的。所以我认为对人们来说重要的一点是，维多利亚式是一个非常宽泛的描述。它实际上是对一个时代、一个时期的描述。这就像如果你说，我是80年代的音乐，你可能指的是朋克、流行音乐或一百万种不同的风格。它并没有真正告诉你那音乐是什么。
It's a little bit similar with describing Victorian architecture because it went through various evolutions from Italianate to Gothic, and then eventually towards the late 1800s, you land on this style known as Queen Anne, or Queen Anne Revival, which is kind of interesting because it's sort of mashed together a lot of the previous styles, sort of mashed together a lot of the previous styles, sort of Mr. Potato Head style a little bit. I mean Roman and I
描述维多利亚式建筑也有点类似，因为它经历了从意大利风格到哥特风格的各种演变，然后最终在19世纪后期，你落脚于这种被称为“安妮女王”或“安妮女王复兴”的风格，这有点有趣，因为它有点把之前的许多风格混合在一起，有点像“土豆先生”风格。我是说，罗曼和我
used to you know be really into punk music growing up so the way that an analogy for people who aren't architecture experts if you think about it the earliest kind of punk music like the Ramones is very simple direct you know four on the floor one two, two, three, four. Within a couple of years though, you get bands like The Clash that take punk and mash, reggae and disco and all these other kinds of styles into it. And that's similar to what happened with the Queen Anne's.
过去常常，你知道的，在成长过程中非常迷恋朋克音乐，所以对于不是建筑专家的人来说，如果你想一想，最早的朋克音乐，比如雷蒙斯乐队（The Ramones），非常简单直接，你知道的，四四拍的节奏，一、二、三、四。然而，几年之内，你就会看到像冲击合唱团（The Clash）这样的乐队，他们吸收了朋克音乐，并将雷鬼、迪斯科和所有其他各种风格融入其中。这类似于安妮女王式建筑发生的情况。
These architecture, we're getting very exuberant and excited about all the possibilities, new materials, better transportation to get prefabricated materials up the West Coast. And because they were able to kind of go crazy, they did. And this is all because Oakland, even though it's attached to the continent a little more closely than San Francisco is, it was later to develop. So there was more space because it isn't on the end of a peninsula. And there was more space because it isn't on the end of a peninsula.
这些建筑，我们对所有的可能性、新材料、将预制材料运送上西海岸的更好交通感到非常兴奋和狂热。因为它们能够变得疯狂，所以它们确实这样做了。这一切都是因为奥克兰，尽管它比旧金山更紧密地与大陆相连，但它的发展较晚。所以有更多的空间，因为它不在半岛的尽头。并且有更多的空间，因为它不在半岛的尽头。
And there was more time. You know, it was building up a little bit later than San Francisco, not a lot later, but a little bit later. And so they had this time to both get fancy stuff from the East Coast and they had space to explode and it truly exploded into this queen ant style. And the other part of that equation is they had the money. Yes. Because after 1870, Oakland was the hub of the Transcontinental Railroad,
还有更多的时间。你知道，它的建设比旧金山稍晚一些，虽然不是晚很多，但确实晚了一些。所以他们有时间从东海岸买到华丽的东西，也有空间去大爆发，它确实爆发成了这种安妮女王风格。这个公式的另一部分是他们有钱。是的。因为1870年后，奥克兰成为了横贯大陆铁路的枢纽，
which instantly brought massive amounts of wealth to what had been a tiny little town, a decade before. I mean, one of the first European-owned homes in Oakland was basically built with like driftwood and scrap, you know, materials. And then two decades later, flash forward within the span of a single generation, all of a sudden you've got people building homes
这瞬间给在十年前还是一个小镇的地方带来了巨额财富。我的意思是，奥克兰最早由欧洲人拥有的房屋之一，基本上是用浮木和废旧材料建造的。然后二十年过去了，在短短一代人的时间里，突然之间你发现人们开始建造带有
with like ballrooms and organs and indoor bowling alleys and things like that. So really the railroad is what changed things overnight and with this huge influx of money, of course that attracted industrialistsists and architects to serve them. Yeah. And they really went all out. And that's this queen-hand style is kind of the, is the everything style of, you know,
舞厅、风琴、室内保龄球馆等设施的房屋。所以铁路确实改变了一夜之间的一切，随着这笔巨额资金的涌入，它当然吸引了工业家和建筑师来为他们服务。是的。他们真的全力以赴。而这种安妮女王风格有点像是万能风格，你知道的，
turrets and scallops and filigree and colors and so, and these original queens, which you can see a few of them. They're not, they're not plentiful and, and Oakland, but they are about the size of a city block. They're, they're quite, they're not plentiful in Oakland, but they are about the size of a city block. They're quite... They're huge. And all the terms that you just mentioned for people that aren't familiar with them, I think everyone knows what a gingerbread house looks like, and a lot of these queen and sort
有塔楼、扇贝形饰物、细丝花边、色彩等等，而这些原汁原味的安妮女王式建筑，你可以看到一些。它们在奥克兰并不多，但它们大约有一个城市街区那么大。它们相当……它们在奥克兰并不多，但它们大约有一个城市街区那么大。它们相当……它们太巨大了。对于不熟悉这些词的人来说，你刚刚提到的所有术语，我想大家都知道姜饼屋是什么样子的，很多这样的安妮女王式建筑都有点
of evoke that gingerbread house feeling, with like the witch's hat style turrets. You know, really interesting little, for, you know, to put it maybe colloquially, little doodads and details and swirls and things like that on all the little banisters and value strades and whatnot. It was like a very much more is better approach. It's like anything that they could cram onto these houses for a little while, they really did.
让人联想到那种姜饼屋的感觉，比如带有女巫帽风格的塔楼。你知道，非常有趣的小物件，用通俗的话来说，就是所有的小扶手、栏杆之类的东西上都有小装饰品、细节和漩涡。这是一种“越多越好”的方法。这就像是一段时期内，任何他们能塞进这些房子的东西，他们真的都塞进去了。
And so like any sort of big fancy thing that big fancy rich people have, eventually the style kind of trickles down into some pain more manageable, which is a thing called a queen and cottage. So can you describe what that looks like, what that process was, and where you see them in Oakland?
因此，就像大富豪们拥有的任何那种又大又fancy的东西一样，这种风格最终会流传下来，变成一种更容易控制的形式，这就是所谓的“安妮女王小屋”。所以你能描述一下它是什么样子的，这个过程是怎样的，以及你在奥克兰哪里能看到它们吗？
Absolutely. So the wealthiest people in Oakland wanted their visitors from Europe and from the East Coast to be impressed. So they developed these giant manners in the states around the shores of Lake Merritt and up in the foothills of Oakland. But within a decade or two, the process of building these homes and the materials became a lot more affordable.
当然。因此，奥克兰最富有的人希望他们在欧洲和东海岸的访客留下深刻印象。因此，他们在梅里特湖畔周围的庄园和奥克兰的山麓上建造了这些巨大的庄园。但在一二十年内，建造这些房屋的过程和材料变得更加实惠。
And there was a growing middle class in Oakland because all these new businesses that were popping up after the railroad came to town had a whole layer of kind of middle management and other sort of business people that could also afford to build a home. And think about it back then, when people built a home, it wasn't like now where I think a lot of people expect to move every couple of years.
奥克兰的中产阶级不断壮大，因为铁路进城后涌现的所有新企业都拥有一整层中层管理人员和其他各类商业人士，他们也买得起房子。想想看，在那个时候，当人们建造房屋时，并不像现在这样，我想很多人都期望每隔几年就搬一次家。
Like, transience is a lot more incorporated in our society and our culture these days. But back then, when you were building a home, you were like, this is the home that I'm going to live in for the rest of my life. So people really put a lot of work and thought and detail into it. And they couldn't quite go up to the same scale in terms of size as maybe the, you know, their bosses or the wealthy elite, but they could borrow a lot of these elements and put them into maybe like a one-story house instead of a two or three-story house. And incorporate some of the same elements like scalloped shingles and things like that that you would see on some of the bigger ones.
就像流动性在当今我们的社会和文化中更加根深蒂固一样。但在当时，当你建造一栋房子时，你会想，这就是我要度过余生的房子。所以人们真的在其中投入了大量的工作、思考和细节。在规模上，他们可能无法达到与老板或富裕精英相同的水平，但他们可以借用许多这些元素，把它们融入到单层住宅中，而不是两层或三层的住宅中。并融入一些你在一些较大的住宅上会看到的相同元素，比如扇贝形瓦片等。
So it's basically just a miniature version of these giant queen and sort of mansions in the states. And so this queen and style that you can see sort of peppered throughout Oakland was really of a moment in time. And then it kind of fell out of fashion. What replaced it? Well, I can talk about what replaced it in a second. But first one, I'm going to explain a little bit about why it fell out of fashion.
所以它基本上只是这些庄园里巨大的安妮女王式豪宅的微缩版。所以这种你可以看到点缀在奥克兰各处的安妮女王风格确实是一个时代的产物。然后它有点过时了。取而代之的是什么？嗯，我一会儿可以谈谈取而代之的是什么。但首先我要稍微解释一下它为什么会过时。
Oh, OK, please. As I was saying, this was sort of like, there was a lot of new technology coming into play at this time that allowed architects to go get very creative, shall we say. And an analogy that kind of reminds me of is like at the beginning of the internet when people had like geocities websites. And you know, you were searching on Netscape and Internet Explorer and every website had like 3D fonts and like spinning cubes and like pixelated flames. And it was just because you could do it.
哦，好的，请说。正如我所说，这有点像是，当时有很多新技术投入使用，使建筑师能够变得非常有创意，我们可以这么说。让我想起的一个比喻就像互联网刚出现时，人们有像地理城市（Geocities）这样的网站。你知道的，你在Netscape和Internet Explorer上搜索，每个网站都有3D字体、旋转的立方体和像素化的火焰。这只是因为你能做到。
You know, it was just like this is new. I'm going to show off the possibility. And within a couple years people realize this is incredibly distracting. It's not necessary. It looks gaudy and ridiculous and it became very out of fashion. Now when you see a website like that, if you go along the way back machine or something like that, it feels kind of quaint and sort of humorous. There was kind of a similar trajectory with Victorian architecture.
你知道的，这就像这是新的。我要展示这种可能性。几年之内，人们意识到这极其令人分心。这是不必要的。它看起来花哨而荒谬，并且变得非常过时。现在，当你看到这样一个网站时，如果你通过时光倒流机器（Wayback Machine）或类似的东西去查看，它会觉得有点古雅和幽默。维多利亚式建筑也有类似的发展轨迹。
There was a couple of factors that played into it falling out of fashion. There was the end of the century, and I think any time you sort of flip that calendar page to a new century people are looking for sort of a fresh start. It had kind of hit its end point. The Victorian styles were very popular for a time, but by the end, not everyone was a fan. There was one critic who warned that, quote, the English house was strangling itself
有几个因素导致它过时。那是世纪末，我想每当你把日历翻到新世纪时，人们都在寻找一个新的开始。它已经走到了终点。维多利亚式风格流行了一段时间，但到了最后，并不是每个人都是它的粉丝。有一位评论家警告说，引用他的话说，“英国房屋正在用其过去辉煌的内在来勒死自己”，
with the entrails of its own past glories, which is quite a vivid description. But I can't say too far off the mark with some of these sort of overdone ornamentation little houses. There was also sort of a dark side of this. Some of the theories about why the Victorian styles fell out of fashion at this time is because they were really representing European styles, Italian and French and English styles.
这是一个非常生动的描述。但我不能说对于这些过于夸张的装饰小房子来说，这个描述离目标太远。这其中也有黑暗的一面。关于维多利亚式风格在此时过时的原因的一些理论是，它们真的代表了欧洲风格，意大利、法国和英国风格。
There was a rising type of nativism in the United States at the end of the century, at the end of the 1800s, because of the rise in immigration. There was a backlash to that, and this is when you see colonial revivals coming up. The simple, good old American Protestant work ethic. We're going to represent, you know, these values with our architecture now instead of the glamorous or decadent European style that came to be associated with the gilded era. And so specifically in California,
在世纪之交，即18th世纪末，由于移民的增加，美国出现了一种不断上升的本土主义。对此出现了反弹，这就是你看到殖民地复兴兴起的时候。简单、优秀的美国新教工作伦理。我们现在要用我们的建筑来代表这些价值观，而不是那些与镀金时代联系在一起的迷人或颓废的欧洲风格。因此，特别是在加利福尼亚，
two East Bay architects that really became prominent in the era just following the Victorian time was Bernard Maybeck and Julia Morgan. Maybeck lived in Berkeley, Julia Morgan was raised in Oakland and later went to school in Berkeley before attending architectural school in Paris, but their styles really were the beginning
在维多利亚时代之后的时期真正崭露头角的两位东湾建筑师是伯纳德·梅贝克（Bernard Maybeck）和朱莉娅·摩根（Julia Morgan）。梅贝克住在伯克利，朱莉娅·摩根在奥克兰长大，后来在伯克利上学，之后在巴黎建筑学校学习，但他们的风格确实是
of a original California style of architecture because everything previous to this had been kind of copying and mimicking the European styles and all of a sudden, Maybeck and Morgan and people and their school of thought realized we should create homes that sort of reflect the beauty of the East Bay Hills, for example. And so all of a sudden, you get these more simple cottages
原创加利福尼亚建筑风格的开端，因为在此之前的一切都在复制和模仿欧洲风格，突然之间，梅贝克、摩根和他们的思想流派意识到，我们应该创造出能够反映东湾山丘之美的住宅，例如。因此，突然之间，你得到了这些更简单的乡村小屋，
that are brown or earth tone and sort of blend into the hills and the landscape much more naturally than something with like a pink witch's cap on it. Yeah, yeah. Well, I think the thing I love about California is you see both of them. You see this history of its driving to be European and then learning to be a Californian
它们是棕色或大地色系的，比那些带有粉红色女巫帽的房子更自然地融入山丘和景观中。是的，是的。嗯，我认为我喜欢加利福尼亚的地方在于你两者都能看到。你既能看到它努力成为欧洲风格的历史，又能看到它学会成为加利福尼亚风格的历史，在某种程度上，这正是我们来到这里后都在做的事情。没错，我的意思是，你曾在美丽的奥克兰市中心为你的播客录音多年，所以你知道在奥克兰市中心和周边社区散步是什么感觉，你会看到新艺术运动风格的建筑旁边就是维多利亚式建筑，旁边又是现代主义建筑。
is kind of what we all kind of do when we get out here, in a way. Exactly, I mean, you famously recorded your podcast from beautiful downtown Oakland for many years, and so you know what it's like to walk around downtown Oakland and the surrounding neighborhoods, you'll see Art Nouveau next to Victoria and next to Moderness.
然后在街角，在住宅区，你会看到工匠风格的房子旁边是意大利风格的房子。我的意思是，所有的风格都融合在一起，非常类似于加利福尼亚文化本身所代表的东西。谢谢你，利亚姆，和我聊天。我真的很感激。
And then down the street, in a residential neighborhood, you'll see a craftsman next to an Italian eight. And I mean, it's just all the styles blend together very similar to what California culture itself kind of has come to represent. Thank you, Liam, for talking with me. I really appreciate it.
这很有趣。罗曼，这绝对是一种荣幸。谢谢你邀请我。休息过后，我们将与执行制片人德兰妮·霍尔（Delaney Hall）谈谈究竟什么才算大地色，请继续收听。[背景音乐]新墨西哥州北部的风景会让你确信米色是一种被严重低估的颜色。这里是高海拔沙漠。除了点缀在山丘上的低矮皮尼昂松和杜松外，没有多少树木。因此，视野开阔，地质地貌尽收眼底。红褐色的岩石、焦糖色的台地以及带有古铜色和赭石色条纹的悬崖。一千多年来，
It's fun. Roman, it's been an absolute pleasure. Thanks for having me. Coming up after the break, we talked to Executive Producer Delaney Hall about what exactly qualifies as an Earth tone after this. [♪ Music playing in background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the background, in the The landscape in northern New Mexico will convince you that beige is a criminally underrated color. It's a high altitude desert here. There aren't many trees except for the low-growing pimeons and junipers that dot the hills. And so the vistas are big and the geology is right there for you to take in. The red brown rocks and the caramel-colored maces and the cliffs streaked with bronze and ochre. And for more than a thousand years,
这里建筑一直被地形所塑造。该地区的早期建造者没有多少机会获得木材、锡或岩石。他们拥有大量的是泥土和粘土，这正是他们用来制作土坯砖的原料，他们用泥土将其堆砌并粘合在一起。这里的建筑反映了大地的颜色，因为它们就是用泥土建造的。几年前，我制作了一整期99
the architecture of this place has been shaped by the terrain. Early builders in the region didn't have much access to wood or tin or rock. What they had in great abundance was dirt and clay, and that's what they used to make Adobe bricks, which they stacked and stuck with mud. The buildings here reflect the color of the earth because that's what they're made of. A couple years ago, I made a whole 99
PI播客，讲述了我居住的城镇圣达菲的土坯历史和政治。你可能听过。它探讨了有关历史保护和士绅化的重大问题。但其中有一个小元素，我没有深入探讨。那就是围绕着灰泥颜色的荒谬争论，一直持续到今天。曾有过诉讼、漫长的市议会会议以及关于颜色含义以及什么构成大地色的辩论，我是说关于看东西的本质的争论。这只大黑鸟有很多话要说，
PI episode about the history and politics of Adobe in Santa Fe, the town where I live. You might have heard it. It got into big questions about historic preservation and gentrification. But there's this one small element that town where I live. You might have heard it. It got into big questions about historic preservation and gentrification. But there's this one small element that I didn't explore in much depth. And that is the absurd fights that happen to this day around the color of Stucco. There have been lawsuits and long city council meetings and debates about the meaning of color and what constitutes an earth tone, and I'm serious the very nature of what it means to see. This large blackbird has a lot to say. of which I will get to, but first I want to introduce you to Rose Simpson. Who does the most incredible crow in personation I have ever heard? What did you say?
我待会儿会讲到，但首先我想向大家介绍罗斯·辛普森（Rose Simpson）。她能发出我听过的最不可思议的乌鸦叫声。你刚才说什么？
Ah, okay, really? Ah, okay, I didn't know. And okay, more relevant to this story, Rose also has a deep connection to a doby construction. She's an artist from the Santa Clara Pueblo, which is just north of Santa Fe. And she told me the story that got it just how much Adobe means to her. She went to art school on the East Coast
啊，好吧，真的吗？啊，好吧，我不知道。好吧，与这个故事更相关的是，罗斯也与土坯建筑有着深厚的渊源。她是来自圣克拉拉普韦布洛的艺术家，该普韦布洛位于圣达菲正北部。她给我讲了一个故事，这个故事完美诠释了土坯对她有多么重要。她去东海岸上艺术学校，
where she was dismayed to live not in a solid mud house as she had for a lot of her childhood, but in a wood framed house. You can hear through the walls. You can hear scratching and there's a space where things can live in the walls. All those things are very unnerving to me. So unnerving that she eventually moved back to New Mexico.
令她沮丧的是，她住的不是像她童年大部分时间那样坚固的泥屋，而是木结构房屋。你能透过墙壁听到声音。你能听到抓挠声，墙里还有生物可以生存的空间。所有这些事情都让我感到非常不安。如此不安，以至于她最终搬回了新墨西哥州。
One of my main goals to come home for real was just to be in a dopey home, you know? I felt like living in a frame house was like being in a tent, like a glorified tent. This isn't substantial. Adobe is substantial. It's one of the oldest building materials in the world. And it's been used for many centuries by both the Hispanic and Native American people
我真正回家的主要目标之一就是住进土坯房，你知道吗？我觉得住在框架房里就像住在帐篷里，就像一个美化的帐篷。这不是坚实的。土坯是坚实的。它是世界上最古老的建筑材料之一。几个世纪以来，这里的人们一直都在使用它，包括西班牙裔和美洲原住民。
of this area. Rose is Tewa, one of the indigenous Pueblo groups of New Mexico, and her family has a long tradition of building with mud. But it really wasn't until she moved back from the East Coast that she recognized the degree to which the literal dirt of northern New Mexico was a huge part of her life. It's the material she uses for pottery, and sculpture, and home building. You know, I didn't snap that how much this place was made of clay was earth. You know, we eat, and we pray,
罗斯是蒂瓦人（Tewa），是新墨西哥州的土著普韦布洛族群之一，她的家族有着用泥土建筑的悠久传统。但直到她从东海岸搬回来，她才真正意识到新墨西哥州北部的泥土在多大程度上构成了她生活的重要部分。这是她用来制作陶器、雕塑和房屋建筑的材料。你知道，我没有突然意识到这个地方是由粘土、由大地组成的。你知道的，我们吃饭，我们祈祷，
with these vessels that are clay from the earth. We live in vessels that are from the earth. Literally, it's the same clay pot just turned into a house with a roof and a long time ago those roofs were mud you know so you were surrounded on all sides with earth. So this is the context of Adobe in the region an earth and construction style born out of the material scarcity and climate of the desert. But in Santa Fe, not far from where Rose lives, Adobe has gone from being just a fact of life to being city code.
我们使用的器皿都是来自大地的粘土。我们住在来自大地的容器里。从字面上看，它就是同一个陶罐，只是变成了一座带屋顶的房子，而在很久以前，那些屋顶是泥土的，所以你四面八方都被泥土包围着。这就是该地区土坯的背景，这是一种诞生于沙漠物质稀缺和气候的土木建筑风格。但在圣达菲，离罗斯住的地方不远，土坯已经从一种生活现实变成了城市法规。
And that's where these fights about color, about what is and isn't an earth tone come in. A lot of my buildings I use a cooler tone of stucco. It's still an earth tone, but it can sometimes have a little bit of green in it to kind of think about like wet clay. Trey Jordan is an architect in Santa Fe. I spoke with him for that original Adobe story I did. He's worked on projects in the city's historic district where buildings have to comply with a number of rules that keep the city looking low and brown in the Adobe style. New projects and renovations in the historic districts have to be approved by a historic board. They are the guardians of the Santa Fe aesthetic, making sure that everything meets the code. It's things like a flat roof, window placement, away from X-Year-Corps of the building,
这就是关于颜色的争论、关于什么是和不是大地色的争论切入的地方。我的很多建筑都使用了较冷色调的 stucco（灰泥）。它仍然是一种大地色，但有时会带有一点绿色，让人联想到湿粘土。特雷·乔丹（Trey Jordan）是圣达菲的一名建筑师。我在我做的那个最初的土坯故事中采访过他。他曾参与该市历史区的项目，这些项目必须遵守许多规则，以保持圣达菲低矮、棕色和土坯风格的外观。历史区的新项目和翻新项目必须获得历史委员会的批准。他们是圣达菲美学的守护者，确保一切都符合规范。其中包括平屋顶、窗户位置、远离建筑物的特定部分、
a majority of Earth-Tone Stucco surface. And it's that Stucco part of the code that has caused some problems. It states that buildings, quote, shall predominantly be brown, tan, or local earth tones. The code only says earth tone, which is pretty vague, so that's become kind of a tricky area. Trey himself has run up against the code, despite his best efforts not to.
大部分是大地色灰泥表面。正是规范中的灰泥部分引起了一些问题。它规定建筑“应当主要为棕色、褐色或当地的大地色”。规范只说大地色，这相当含糊，所以这已经成为一个棘手的领域。特雷本人也曾违反过这一规定，尽管他尽了最大努力避免这样做。
He is not a rule breaker by nature, but he does favor those cooler stucco tones. In one case, he stucko to home a greenish, grayish color, and then learned the historic board was displeased with him. A couple of age board members, apparently, went out to the house to hold up stucco samples to the walls. They were trying to prove tray had misled them. It turned into a bit of a fight, which tray ultimately won.
他天生不是一个破坏规则的人，但他确实偏爱那些较冷的灰泥色调。有一次，他把家里粉刷成了一种偏绿又偏灰的颜色，随后得知历史委员会对很不满。显然，几位年龄较大的委员会成员亲自去到那座房子，将灰泥样品举到墙边比对。他们试图证明特雷误导了他们。这演变成了一场小小的争执，特雷最终赢了。
The ordinance says Earth's tone stucco, and I said I can easily go find... Earth's that's that tone. But one color in particular has continued to be problematic here in Santa Fe. And that's green. It's a color you can find in the landscape, but it doesn't comply with the usual brown stucco regime. The city has been involved in a dispute
法令规定必须使用大地色系的灰泥，我说我可以轻松找到……符合那个色调的大地色。然而，圣菲有一种颜色尤其一直是个问题，那就是绿色。这是一种你能在风景中找到的颜色，但它不符合通常的棕色灰泥制度。这座城市卷入了一场纠纷，
that has gone on for years with a couple of homeowners in the historic district, who stuccoed their house a forest green color. They did this without permission from the historic board. When they asked for after the fact approval, they were denied. They appealed to the city council, which debated the issue for more than two hours. The assistant city attorney noted that there was limited visibility of the home from the street, which led to a long conversation about the meaning of limited visibility.
这场纠纷与历史街区的几位房主持续了多年，他们把房子粉刷成了森林绿色。他们未经历史委员会的允许就这么做了。当他们事后申请批准时，遭到拒绝。他们向市议会提起上诉，市议会就此问题辩论了两个多小时。城市助理律师指出，从街上对这栋房子的可见度有限，这引发了关于“有限可见度”含义的长篇大论。
The attorney sounded like she was laying out a Zen Kowon when she said, quote, if something is visible, whether or not it is fully visible, if something has limited visibility, it is visible. The City Council ultimately voted against granting an exception to the homeowners. The homeowners then appealed the city's decision to the district court and were once again denied.
当这位女律师说出下面这番话时，听起来就像是在摆出一个禅宗公案：她说，“如果某事是可见的，无论它是否完全可见，如果某事具有有限的可见度，那么它就是可见的。”市议会最终投票反对给予这些房主特例。随后，房主们将市议会的决定上诉至地区法院，并再次遭到拒绝。
But unwilling to give up, they filed a petition with the state court of appeals. Their lawyer parsed the language of the code, which requires brown, tan, or local earth tones. The lawyer wrote, the use of the disjunctive or means that the earth tones described are colors that are not brown and are not tan and are some other color. Once again, the homeowners lost. The city eventually filed a
但他们不愿放弃，又向州上诉法院提起了请愿。他们的律师仔细分析了法典的字眼，法典要求使用棕色、晒黑的颜色或当地的大地色。律师写道：“使用析取词‘或’意味着所描述的大地色是不棕色、不晒黑且属于其他颜色的颜色。”房主们再次败诉。市方最终提起了一起
lawsuit to try and force them to comply with the color change. Okay, I'm just going to try to see if the greenhouse is still green. I emailed back and forth with the homeowner, who did not want to talk with me for this story. She said they've sold the property and moved out of state for family reasons. The last time the house went up for sale, the real estate listings showed a decidedly green looking house Hmm It still looks kind of grayish greenish hard to say and when I drove by recently I couldn't figure out if it had been Restucked or not I
诉讼，试图强迫他们遵从颜色更改。好吧，我只是想看看那栋绿色的房子是不是还是绿色的。我和那位房主进行了邮件往来，她不想就这个故事跟我交流。她说他们为了家庭原因已经把房产卖掉并搬出了州。房子上次挂牌出售时，房地产房源信息显示那是一栋非常绿色的房子。嗯，它看起来还是有点灰绿色，很难说。而且我最近开车路过时，根本看不出它有没有重新粉刷过。
Think it's God, it's really hard to tell Maybe it depends on the light it's really hard to tell. Maybe it depends on the light? It's really hard to tell. Okay, so maybe it is not that easy to find the line between green and brown. But Rose Simpson thinks this whole debate over Earthtones misses the entire point. She thinks it is laughable the length Santa Fe has gone to keep the whole city looking like a particular kind of mud construction, even when it's not.
我觉得它已经变了，真的很难说。也许这取决于光线？真的很难说。好吧，也许在绿色和棕色之间划清界限并没有那么容易。但罗丝·辛普森认为，这场关于大地色的争论完全抓错了重点。她认为，圣菲为了让整个城市看起来像某种特定的泥土建筑（即使事实并非如此）而做出如此极端的举动，简直可笑。
Even when it's just Earthtone's stucco, whatever that means, over a wood frame. Let's get real people, you know? Like this is where we're at, it's sub-pretending. The fact that we would perpetuate a style rather than actually do the work to build the Adobe wall, where is the integrity? We're really seriously, I mean there's an incredible metaphor that an Adobe wall has hell of a lot more integrity than a frame wall. Santa Fe can be an absurd place, obsessed with its own highly engineered sense of authenticity.
即使它只是木框架上的一层大地色灰泥（不管这意味着什么）。大家现实一点吧，好吗？这就是我们的现状，充满了伪装。我们延续一种风格，而不是真正去做建造土坯墙的工作，这种做法的诚意何在？说真的，我的意思是，土坯墙比框架墙具有多得多的诚意，这是一个不可思议的比喻。圣菲可能是一个荒谬的地方，痴迷于其自身高度人为设计的真实感。
of authenticity. But there's also something touching, at least to me, about the great lengths the city will go to preserve its history and its sense of itself. Where else would I be called upon to think about the nuances of mud? Where else would I come to know the names of commercial stucco colors, just off the top of my head? Colors like tumbleweed and cottonwood and desert lace. Where else would city counselors talk for hours, like philosophers trying to parse the meaning of green? Thank you for being with us for 500 and two episodes. It's been a real honor. I realize that sounded kind of final.
真实感。但这座城市为了保护其历史和自我意识而付出的巨大努力，至少对我来说，也有动人的一面。除了这里，还有哪里会要求我去思考泥土的细微差别呢？除了这里，还有哪里能让我对商业灰泥颜色的名字如数家珍？比如滚草、三角叶杨和沙漠花边。除了这里，还有哪里的市议员会像哲学家一样讨论数小时，试图解析绿色的含义？感谢大家陪伴我们度过第500零二集。这真是莫大的荣幸。我意识到这听起来像是要结束了。
We're going to keep going. It's just been an honor up to this point and then we'll just keep going. Regardless. thanks. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Digital Director Kirk Colestead and Executive Producer Delaney Hall, mixed in tech production by Martin Gonzales, production assistant by Jacob Maldonado Medina, original music by a director of sound, swan rial, fact checking by Graham Haysha. The rest of the team includes Vivian Leigh, Christopher Johnson,
我们要继续做下去。走到这一步已经是一种荣誉，接下来我们还会继续前进。无论如何，谢谢大家。本周的《99%无形》由数字总监柯克·科尔斯特德和执行制片人德兰妮·霍尔制作，混音与技术制作由马丁·冈萨雷斯负责，制作助理是雅各布·马尔多纳多·梅迪纳，原创音乐由声音总监斯旺·里尔创作，事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙负责。团队其他成员包括维维安·李、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、
Emmett Fitzgerald, Jason Dillion, Chris Baroube, Lashemadon, Sophia Klatsker, Joe Rosenberg, intern, Sarah Baker, and me, Roman Mars. We are a part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building, and beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、杰森·狄龙、克里斯·巴鲁贝、拉谢马顿、索菲娅·克拉茨克、乔·罗森伯格、实习生萨拉·贝克，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们现在是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客大家庭的一员，总部设在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区上城潘多拉大楼以北六个街区。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与节目讨论。
You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Ork. We're on Instagram and read it too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99pi.org. If you think about it, the earliest kind of punk music, like the Ramones, is very simple. 1, 2, 3, 4! There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，也可以@节目 @99PI Org。我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。你可以在 99pi.org 上找到我喜爱的其他 Stitcher 节目的链接，以及《99PI》过去的每一集。如果你仔细想想，最早的朋克音乐，比如雷蒙斯乐队，非常简单。1, 2, 3, 4！本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。